the oceans play a huge role in really
every elemental cycle they they have a
global impact on
uh the workings of the earth really and
so
uh
we are focusing on one aspect of that
that we know relatively little about
how do microbes work together to fix
carbon to transfer carbon amongst
themselves where does that carbon go how
quickly does that
carbon turn over and so at some point
we'd like to put all of these data
together think about what we already
know now about the carbon cycle and see
how this new information might change
how we think about it what we predict
from it
the particular research area that we've
chosen is an area that has been poorly
studied in the past due to analytical
challenges
that we feel now are are ready
to be applied to this question it's not
just how climate change affects the
microbes but really then how microbes
further affect the climate in in
response to those changes
well one of the things we've already
learned in our workshop so far is
bringing together people of really
diverse backgrounds
allows us
access to
novel perspectives and different fields
that could be helpful certainly
we think that a better understanding of
this system will give us a really
powerful predictive knowledge about what
will happen in a changing climate so so
the methods are there now the interest
is there and i think it wasn't possible
10 years ago to say this but but it is
now
[Music]